كما تعرضت العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف لقصف
جوي روسي فيما اعلنت سلطات العاصمه التاهب
الجوي ودعت المدنيين الى البقاء في اماكن
امنه وقد اعلن سلاح الجو الاوكراني انه
اسقط مسير من نوع بيرقدار في سماء كييف
بعد ان فقد السيطره عليها بسبب عطل فني
بينما قالت الاداره العسكريه في كييف ان
انفجارات وحرائق اندلعت في حي سلم يانسكي
بالعاصمه
معنى من ميكو لايف مراسل الجزيره تامر
الصمادي تامر كيف يبدو الوضع اليوم في
اوكرانيا على خلفيه هذا التصعيد
نعم حاله من التاهب الجوي سهام هل انذار
المتواصل في العاصمه كييف في عديد
المقاطعات لاسيما المقاطعات الجنوبيه حتى
هذه اللحظه العديد من المقاطعات لاسيما
تحت حاله الانذار الجوي بالنسبه للسلطات
الاوكرانيه هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه تحدثت
صباح هذا اليوم ان او حذرت من تصاعد خطر
هجمات روسيه جديده واسعه النطاق من البحر
الاسود وبحر قازوين
المناطق الجنوبيه في الحقيقه سهام طيله
يوم امس واليوم وهي لا تهدا القصف يتواصل
على عديد المواقع على عديد الجبهات على
عديد المحاور لكن تظل مقاطعه خيرسون
القريبه من هنا المجاوره لملكو لايف تحت
القصف العنيف والشديد والمكثف هذا صباح
تحدث حاكم خرسون الاوكراني عن ان القصف
الروسي تواصل طيله الليل وحتى
الصباح واتحدث عن اكثر من مئه هجوم روسي
تعرض له قلب المدينه خيرسون بالاضافه الى
القرى والبلدات الواقعه على طول خط التماس
تحدث عن استخدام القوات الروسيه للمدفعيه
الثقيله صواريخ جراد بالاضافه الى
الطائرات المسيره من دون طيار وقال بان
القوات الروسيه من الجو بدات بالقاء
القنابل التي وصفها بالموجهه والدقيقه
التي تستهدف الاحياء السكنيه والبنيه
التحتيه الخساره على الصعيد على الانسان
كانت متفاقمه طيله يوم امس واول من امس
كان الحديث يجري عن عشرات القتلى والجرحى
في صفوف المدنيين خيرسون مغلقه بالكامل
سهام في الحقيقه بقرار من السلطات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه وذلك على واقع اشتداد
القصف اول من امس تمكنا باذن خاص من
القوات الاوكرانيه من الدخول الى المدينه
رصدنا الواقع الانساني الصعب انقطاع
التيار الكهربائي في مناطق كثيره كما تقول
السلطات بالاضافه الى
الماء الجثث كانت ملقاه في الشوارع سيارات
الاسعاف ايضا لم تسلم من القصف الذي كان
ينهمر من الضفه الشرقيه لنهر دنيبر التي
تسيطر عليها القوات الروسيه ونحن رصدنا
ذلك بام العين لكن في المقابل القوات
الاوكرانيه تحديدا قياده عمليات الجنوب
خلال الساعات الاخيره فقط اكدت بان قواتها
ما زالت تقصف بشكل مكثف بالمدفعيه الثقيله
مواقع تموقع تمركز عفوا القوات الروسيه
على طول الضفه الشرقيه من نهر دنيبر خرجت
الناطقه او المتحدثه باسم قياده عمليات
الجنوب قبل قليل وقالت بان القوات
الاوكرانيه تمكنت من تدمير اكثر من عشرين
قطعه ثقيله عسكريه بطبيعه الحال للقوات
الروسيه هناك وتحدثت عن تدمير اكثر من 15
مدرعه خلال الساعات الماضيه لكن التطور
ايضا اللافته المتسارع هو على جبهه
جبروجيا السلطات الاوكرانيه هناك حاكم
جبروجيا الاوكراني يقول بان القوات
الروسيه قصفت اراضي المقاطعه فقط خلال
الليله الماضيه وحتى هذا الصباح اكثر من
90 مره يتحدث عن دمار كبير يطال اكثر من
خمسه عشره بلده تقع على خط التماس بين
القوات الاوكرانيه والروسيه لكنه في
المقابل يتحدث عن استمرار قصف القوات
الاوكرانيه لمواقع تمركز الروس في ريف
جبروج الجنوبي الحديث عن ميليتوبل توك باك
لكن التطور ايضا المتلاحق المتسارحيه في
المعارك الشرسه في الشرقل بين القوات
الاوكرانيه والروسيه الحديث وفقا لهيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه صباح هذا اليوم عن
اكثر من 60 هجوما صد القوات الاوكرانيه
اكثر من 60 هجوما للقوات الروسيه باتجاه
باخموت مارينكا اف ديفيكا وتقول القوات
الاوكرانيه بان تحديدا المتحدث باسم
القياده الشرقيه الليله الماضيه بان اكثر
من 100 جندي روسي قتلوا في محور باخموت
وان هنالك اكثر من 200 جريحه هذه اللح ظه
في صفوف القوات الروسيه نعم
من نيكولايف شكرا جزيلا لك